this is the end of the legislative
session they burned the midnight oil
last night up here trying to get things
accomplished but there is still quite a
bit of work to do until the budget is
done little else can move forward some
Sunday night there was some movement on
the key issue of the budget the assembly
passed several amended bills including
AB 400 which deals with school choice in
Charter School transportation school
choice is one of the major items
Governor Lombardo wants passed by the
Democratic legislature if not he says
he'll veto the entire budget earlier the
governor vetoed four more bills Chief
among them ab302 which would have
protected gender affirming procedures
the floor activity in the late hours are
a sign of the time constraints but one
way or another the legislative session
ends Monday night are you optimistic
that
what needs to get done can get done
before Sunny die I will give it a 60
chance that we actually get everything
done Democratic Leadership declined to
talk a whole lot on camera on Sunday
because there's so much still in flux up
here at the legislative session but
until lawmakers can get the budget
taking care of those other big items
that we've talked about so much the A's
baseball stadium the movie studios in
southern Nevada that's also on the back
burner we'll see what happens today in
Carson City John langler 8 News Now